la séance est
ouverte le contenduit analytique de la
précédente séance a été
distribué nous n'avons pas reçu
d'observation il y en a-t-il en
séance je n'en vois point le
procèsverbal est donc adopté sous les
réserves
d'usage notre ordre du jour appelle les
explications de vote des groupes et le
vote par scrutin public solennel sur le
projet de loi pour contrôler
l'immigration améliorer
l'intégration monsieur le ministre mes
chers
collègues ce scrutin s'effectuera depuis
les terminaux de vote donc je demande à
chacun d'y être
attentif je vous invite à vous assurer
que vous disposez bien de votre carte de
vote et à vérifier que celle-ci
fonctionne
correctement en l'insérant dans votre
terminale de vote ce qui doit être le
réflexe que vous avez tous maintenant
collectivement en cas de difficulté les
huissiers sont naturellement à votre
disposition avant de passer au vote je
vais donner la parole à ceux de nos
collègues qui ont été inscrits pour
expliquer leur vote et je donne la
parole tout d'abord à Monsieur Yan
brossa pour le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen et écologiste
kqui
vous avez la
parole monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues tout au
long de de ces débats qui nous ont
occupé de nombreux jours sur sur ce
projet de loi relatif à l'immigration
avec mes collègu du groupe communiste
républicain citoyen écologiste nous
avons pensé très fort à la la grande
majorité des étrangers qui vivent sur
notre sol qui travaillent qui produisent
des richesses qui contribuent au
rayonnement de ce pays et qui ont dû se
sentir bien mal en écoutant nos débats
en écoutant un certain nombre
d'outrances qui ont été prononcé ici
oui ce que nous avons ressenti c'est un
immense décalage ce serait vous mentir
que de vous faire croire que nous avons
placé beaucoup d'espoir dans cette loi
c'est le moins qu' puisse dire mais
malgré tout nous espérions qu'elle
puisse au moins permettre à notre pays
d'avancer sur un certain nombre de
sujets notamment sur la question de la
régularisation des travailleurs sans
papiers nous espérions qu'au moins notre
assemblée puisse faire le choix du
pragmatisme qui aurait consisté à
permettre la régularisation de ces
travailleuses de ces travailleurs qui le
méritent non seulement ce projet de loi
tel isue de notre discussion ne nous a
pas permis d'avancer sur ce sujet mais
il a très largement
empiré la situation des étrangers qui
vivent sur notre sol ce texte tel qu'il
ressort de notre discussion il est à la
fois dur cruel et à certains égards
mesquin dur quand il prévoit la fin de
l'automaticité du droit du sol et la
nécessité de 10 ans de résidence en
France pour pouvoir en bénéficier il est
dur lorsqu'il prévoit des quotas
triénaux d'immigration sans critères
explicites il est dur lorsqu'il prévoit
la limitation de l'immigration étudiante
il est dur et il est cruel cruel
lorsqu'il prive l'étranger en situation
régulière d'allocation et de prestations
sociales pendant ces CIN premières
années de présence sur le territoire
français condamné qu'il est à cotiser à
payer des impôts et à ne pas pouvoir
profiter des droits qui existent pour
tous les autres citoyens qui vivent sur
notre territoire il est cruel lorsqu'il
remett en cause l'aide médicale d'État
ce qui constitue une honte absolue il
est cruel lorsqu'il prévoit de réduire
les titres de séjour pour malades qui
profitent à des étrangers notamment
malades du VIH il est dur il est cruel
et il est à certains égards mesquin
lorsqu'il prévoit de supprimer les
transports gratuits pour les
bénéficiaires de l'AME au fond le seul
qui a dit la la vérité du côté de la
majorité sénatoriale c'est le président
rotaillot qui dans le Journal du
Dimanche disait je cite tout ce qui
durcit le droit des étrangers est bon à
prendre de quoi donc sont coupables les
7 millions d'immigrés qui vivent sur
notre sol qui veulent vivre dignement et
qui veulent vivre de leur travail quel
forfait ont-ils donc commis qui justifi
pareil traitement la réalité mes chers
collègues je veux le dire ici très
clairement c'est que tout le Paris sur
lequel repose cet ensemble de
dispositions est totalement faux votre
Paris c'est qu'en dégradant les
conditions d'accueil vous dissuaderez
les étrangers de venir sur notre sol ce
Paris est faux ils viendront mais ils
viendront dans des conditions d'accueil
qui seront déplorables qui seront
lamenta et ce sera du fait des
dispositions qui ont été votées dans le
cadre de cette de cette cette discussion
la
réalité c'est que le mirage c'est vous
qui le présentez en faisant croire que
l'immigration cessera ou se réduira
drastiquement alors même que la misère
grandit alors que les guerres se
multiplient alors que le climat se
dérègle comme jamais dans un contexte
comme celui-là il est vain d'imaginer
que les flux migratoires se tariront il
est vain d'imaginer que l'immigration
cessera et donc la seule question qui se
pose à nous c'est comment nous sommes
capables d'affronter ensemble ce défi
migratoire en assumant les
responsabilités qui sont les nôtres ce
texte il en est loin et surtout il ne
permet pas l'intégration comment
intégrer dès lors qu'on se refuse à
régulariser des hommes et des femmes
sans papiers qui travaillent cotisent et
payent des impôts comment intégrer dès
lors qu'on se refuse à permettre aux
demandeurs d'asile de travailler plutôt
que de vivre des revenus de l'assistance
comment intégrer dès lors que vous
contribuez à faire des étrangers un
groupe à part privé de tout sauf du
droit de se faire exploiter et surtout
ce texte tel qu'il ressort de nos
discussions présente au fond une
contradiction majeure d'un côté il se
revendique en permanence des valeurs de
la République de l'autre ce texte
lui-même en contredisant nos droits
fondamentaux fou au pied les principes
républicains auquel je croyais que nous
étions collectivement attachés bien sûr
un certain nombre d'avancé sont
intervenus notamment grâce aux
amendements portés par mon groupe je
pense par exemple à la question des
victimes des marchands de sommeil et je
me réjouis que nous ayons pu faire voter
un amendement qui permettra d'accorder
un titre de séjour provisoire aux
victimes des marchands de sommeil qui
porte plainte néanmoins cette avanceée
là ne saurait faire effacer l'ensemble
des reculs que ce texte contient et par
conséquent les élus de mon groupe les
sénateurs du groupe communiste
républicain citoyens écologistes ne
pourront que s'opposer à ce texte notre
conviction notre conviction profonde
c'est que la France peut accueillir
qu'elle peut accueillir dignement que
notre honneur c'est d'être capable
d'accueillir celles et ceux qui
cherchent refuge chez nous c'est aussi
d'assumer l'intégration l'intégration
par l'école l'intégration par la langue
l'intégration par le travail voilà les
convictions qui nous animent et qui
continueront de nous animer je vous
remercie
merci la parole
est à notre collègue Michel massé pour
le groupe du Rassemblement démocratique
et social
[Applaudissements]
européen vous avez la parole mon chers
collègues merci
président monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Ministre madame le rapporteur
monsieur le rapporteur mes chers
collègues l'homme n'est réellement libre
que lorsqu'il a contribué à agrandir le
domaine de la liberté ces mots prononcés
par Gaston monerville figure du
radicalisme dans le RSE est l'héritier
il est prononcé le 27 avril
1948 et sa formule aura servi de
boussole à notre groupe tout au long de
l'examen de ce
groupe chers collègues nous avons
travailler dans un climat difficile les
conflits militaires s'intensifient
depuis plus plusieurs mois nous
marchions ce weekend contre
l'antisémitisme les nations et les
communautés semblent se refermer sur
elles-mêm et ce projet sur l'immigration
surtout dans sa version sénatoriale
m'apparaît comme le symptôme d'une
tendance qui nous préoccupe celle du
rejet de l'autre et la méfiance de ce
qui nous est étranger je n'étais pas
encore sénateur lorsque ce texte a été
présenté en Conseil des ministres mais
j'y avais observé des dispositions
constructive et
prometteuse et je pense naturellement
aux articles 3 au 4 dispositions visant
à rendre plus effectives les
otf en tout cas il a rorté une recherche
d'équilibre de compromis ce qui répond
assez bien à l'idée que j'ai d'un
législateur républicain
ensuite je n'étais pas encore membre de
la prestigieuse commission des lois
lorsqu'elle examina ce texte mais ça
m'it pas empêché d'observer la
suppression de l'Ame la restriction du
rapprochement familial ou bien la
limitation du droit du sol pour l'accès
à la
nationalité je vais redire en quelques
mots notre position sur ces sujets
supprimer laame nous sommes contre notre
collègue Véronique Guillotin l'a
parfaitement rappelé éclairé par son
expérience de médecin les malades seront
soignés que ce soit au titre de la me ou
de la mu ils pousseront la porte des et
aucun médecin dans aucun service
d'urgence ne demandera avoir une carte
vitale ou bien avoir un titre de
séjour de plus l'hôpital ne sera pas
payé si laame n'existe
plus sur la restriction du droit du sol
nous sommes contre dans une large
majorité les articles de bis et de terre
nous semblent inappropriés pourquoi
d'une part parce qu'il ne répondent à
rien aux problématiques soulevées par ce
projet de loi et d'autre part parce
qu'ils font peser le poids de vos
inquiétudes sur des enfants et des
adolescents quant aux
dispositionsurcissant le rapprochement
familial encore nous étions opposés
parce qu'elle s'éloignaiit des valeurs
d'humanisme porté par notre
groupe ainsi sur ces sujet nous
espérions convaincre notre assemblée de
changer sa position durant la séance
publique hélas trois fois hélas nous n'y
sommes pas parvenus et nous le
regrettons toutefois au lendemain de
l'examen par la Commission il resta un
espoir les articles 3 et 4 qui demeurit
dans le texte et puis la suite vous la
connaissez il y a donc un constat
d'échec et l'article 4 bis bien qu'il a
été soutenu par certains collègues
pragmatiques n'est pas de nature à nous
satisfaire monsieur le ministre vous
nous avez dit que ces articles 3 et 4 ne
sont pas l'essentiel du texte ce n'est
pas notre
ressenti sans eux ce texte donnera
l'impression de nêtre qu'une nouvelle
réforme parmi d'autres comme cela a déjà
été soulignée nous sommes profondément
convaincus que le travail est un facteur
d'intégration
puissant
nécessaire aussi besoin de production à
notre mode de consommation convaincu que
la clandestinité est source d'exclusion
et de
marginalisation ce qui nous empêche pas
aussi d'être
réaliste réaliste d'abord face à
l'engorgement des préfectures qui ne
sera qu'aggravé par la création d'une
nouvelle voie de régularisation laissé à
la discrétion des administrations et
réaliste ensuite face au constat que le
travail clandestin ne cessera pas avec
ce texte tant il imprègne notre société
et qu'il répond à un réel
besoin cet article 4 donne donc
l'impression d'un geste non assumé celui
de la suppression de l'article 3 dont on
reconnait tous final la nécessité
l'utilité et les besoins auxquels il
répondait vous l'avez compris cette
technique nous satisfait pas d'autant
que le contenu même de ce de ce nouvel
article j'attends de voir comment nos
préfecture puis les juridictions
apprécieront du point de vue du droit
les critères juridiquement
flottants qu'il propose tel que
l'intégration à la société française ou
l'adhésion au mode de vie et aux valeurs
de celle qui resteront totalement à mon
sens
subjective bref nul n'est besoin de
garder le suspense euh insoutenable plus
longtemps la grande majorité du RDSE
votera contre le texte du
Sénat nous avons eu un faux semblant
[Applaudissements]
d'espoir je su montants limité nous
avons eu un faux semblant d'espoir avec
le rétablissement euh de l'article 2
contre la vie rapporteur puis l'abandon
des articles 3 et 4 je vouslaai dire à
confirmeré notre proposition cependant
le sort d'un certain nombre
d'amendements aura participé à forger
notre avis nous regrettons par exemple
qu'on envisage une législation évoquant
explicitement l'assimilation à la
Communauté française nous regrettons
aussi qu'un enfant mineur entre 16 et 18
ans puisse faire l'objet d'une rétention
administrative pour conclure d'ici
quelques semaines nous allons remettre
l'ouvrage sur le métier avec l'examen
d'une voix d'une pardon l'examen d'une
proposition de loi constitutionnelle
relative à la souveraineté de la France
de la nationalité l'immigration et
l'asile notre groupe RDSE saura le dire
comme il le fait lorsque c'est
nécessaire sa position sur ce
texte l'immigration et la nationalité ne
doivent évidemment pas être des sujets
oubliés qu'il y ait une crise migratoire
personne ne le dit mais notre nation a
aussi besoin de faire face à de nombreux
défis économiques écologiques
territoriaux démographiques et autres
nous espérons donc que notre assemblée
dont je défends vigoureusement le
sérieux des travaux veillera à ne pas
s'éloigner du Cap qu'elle sait tenir
celui de l'intérêt général de notre pays
et de placer toujours l'humain au centre
du cercle l'homme n'est réellement libre
que lorsqu'il a contribué à agrandir le
domaine de la liberté merci
merci
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à notre collègue Olivier
bit pour le groupe du Rassemblement des
démocrates progressistes et
indépendants avez la
parole merci Monsieur le le président
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le Président de la
Commission madamees et monsieurs les
rapporteurs mes chers collègues après
une semaine de débat en séance nous
sommes appelés à nous prononcer sur un
texte qui est le fruit d'abord de la
volonté politique du gouvernement et
ensuite d'un compromis qui doit nous
permettre
d'avancer au-delà des postures
l'essentiel est bien là réussir à
relever les défis posés pour notre pays
comme pour tous les pays européens par
une meilleure maîtrise des flux
migratoires par l'absolue nécessité de
mieux protéger nos compatriotes des
délinquants étrangers et de réussir
l'intégration de ceux qui ont vocation à
rester sur le territoire
national la volonté politique du
gouvernement est claire adapter notre
droit aux nouvelles réalités migratoire
que connaissent tous les pays avec
lesquels nous pouvons être
raisonnablement comparés en corrigeant
une trajectoire qui n'est pas soutenable
dans la duré pour notre cohésion
nationale nous nous réjouissons d'abord
de la bonne qualité dans l'ensemble et
sur un sujet aussi passionné des débats
qui se sont déroulés au sein de notre
hémicycle j'exprime nos remerciements
d'abord à Monsieur le Ministre de
l'intérieur pour son sens de l'écoute du
dialogue et du compromis à nos deux
rapporteurs pour le sérieux de leur
travail et au président buffet sans qui
j'en suis certain nous ne son pas nous
ne serions pas arrivés à ce point
d'équilibre je crois que nous pouvons
collectivement nous satisfaire de la
méthode adopté discussion en premier
lieu d'un texte important au Sénat c'est
évidemment un message de confiance en
direction de notre assemblée qui nous a
été envoyé enrichissement du projet
gouvernemental par les travaux en
commission et reprise par le
gouvernement de la quasittalité des
propositions ainsi faites enfin un
travail en sence qui aura permis de
faire encore évoluer le texte par contre
et je le dis très clairement certaines
de ces évolutions nous ont profondément
heurté une en particulier la suppression
de l'aide médicale
d'État nous espérons que l'Assemblée
nationale reviendra sur ce qui
représente à nos yeux une faute morale
et une erreur grave en matière de santé
publique
le dispositif de l'Ame correspond à une
exigence élémentaire
d'humanité notre pays doit rester fidèle
à sa tradition et ses valeurs humanistes
l'idée de conditionner l'accès au soins
d'un individu par hypothèse en
souffrance à la régularité de sa
situation administrative est pour nous
tout simplement
insupportable aussi nous comprenons et
soutenons la démarche des milliers de
soignants qui refusent d'être placés
dans une impasse déontologique du fait
de la loi
aucun argument sérieux ne vient
raésonnablement à l'appui d'une
suppression de la me l'affirmation selon
laquelle la me exercerait un appel d'air
ne repose sur aucun élément chacun le
sait aucune économie ne serait réalisée
en cas de suppression bien au contraire
les pathologies seraient prises en
charge plus tardivement ce qui peut être
dramatique pour les personnes concernées
et encore plus coûteux pour la
collectivité cette mesure si elle était
définitivement adoptée viendrait de plus
opérer un transfert de charge entre
l'État l'État et l'hôpital public et
engorgerit encore davantage nos services
d'urgence non franchement le jeu
politique a aussi ses limites et il
n'est pas possible de jouer ainsi avec
la santé et donc la vie d'être humain si
laame doit être réformée elle l'a
d'ailleurs déjà été réformonsla et nous
étudierons d'ailleurs avec attention le
rapport demandé par le gouvernement à
Monsieur à Messieurs stéphanini et Evin
mais de grâce ne jetons pas le bébé avec
l'eau du bain nous regressons aussi la
suppression de l'article 4 qui prévoyait
un ACC un accès accéléré au marché du
travail pour les demandeurs d'asile dont
le besoin de protection est manifeste
quelle curieuse idée pour la majorité
sénatoriale de préférer ainsi
l'assistana supporté financièrement par
le contribuable à la possibilité ouverte
pour les personnes concernées de
travailler et donc de s'intégrer plus
rapidement ce renoncement à la valeur
travail est difficilement compréhensible
surtout à un moment où nos entreprises
sont en pénurie de main d'œuvre nous
déplorons enfin que les facilités
d'accès à un titre de séjour pour les
médecins diplômés à l'étranger ayant
déjà reçu l'autorisation d'exercer en
France et été rejeté au moment où tant
de territoires souffrent d'un manque de
praticien cette décision est regrettable
d'autant plus qu'il était question même
pas de 400 situations par
an par contre nous nous réjouissons du
maintien d'un dispositif de
régularisation pour les salariés dans
les métiers en tension la majorité
sénatoriale a préféré S remettre
largement au pouvoir discrétionnaire des
préfets et donc Infiné du ministre de
l'intérieur plutôt qu'à des critères
impératifs pour l'administration fixé
par législateur lui-même quitte
d'ailleurs à durcir ce proposé par le
gouvernement pour notre part nous ne
serons pas dans la posture article 3 ou
4 bis la belle affaire l'essentiel est
bien que le dispositif de régularisation
existe dans les métiers en tension pour
les étrangers exprimant la volonté de
s'intégrer ce dispositif viendra
faciliter l'intégration des étrangers
concernés mais viendra aussi satisfaire
un besoin pour nos
entreprises les dispositions concernant
les étrangers délinquants ou constituant
une menace grave pour l'ordre publique
ont également été maintenu c'était pour
nous un dispositif central du texte car
destiné à mieux protéger nos
concitoyens nous nous félicitons du
rétablissement des articles 25 et 8 qui
avaient été supprimé par notre
commission comme nous nous réjouission
de tous les dispositifs spécifiques aux
territoires ultramarins qui ont pu être
adoptés souvent grâce au sénateurs du
groupe
RDPI autre motif de satisfaction
l'adoption de notre abonnement
durcissant les sanctions applicables aux
reconnaissances frauduleuses de
paternité oui le groupe rdpay vtera
majoritairement pour ce texte en sachant
que l'Assemblée nationale reviendra sur
certaines dispositions que nous rejetons
d'autres dispositions sont manifestement
des cavaliers législatifs car portant
sur la nationalité et seront sanctionnés
sans aucun doute par ailleurs il ne
s'agit donc en aucun cas pour nous de
donner quitus à la majorité sénatoriale
mais simplement d'exprimer notre volonté
d'avancer ensemble au Sénat ne pas
adopter ce projet de loi reviendrait
Infiné à se satisfaire de l'état du
droit actuel ce serait prendre une
lourde responsabilité car notre pays a
besoin de renforcer les exigences
concernant l'intégration la protection
des Français la simplification des
procédures et la défense des valeurs de
la publ je vous
remercie
merci la parole est à notre collègue
Marie-Pierre de la Gonterie pour le
groupe socialiste écologiste et
[Applaudissements]
républicain avez la
parole monsieur le président euh
monsieur le
ministre madame monsieur le rapporteur
monsieur le président de la commission
des lois mes chers collègues nous voilà
donc après ces mois de parcours
chaotique de ce projet de loi présenté
il y a plus d'un an au Conseil des
ministres 8 mois après la commission des
lois cette 20 29e loi sur l'immigration
qui promettait de contrôler
l'immigration et améliorer
l'intégration ce que le ministre de
l'Intérieur résumait par la formule être
gentil avec les gentils et méchant avec
les méchants pourtant un an après
l'intégration a totalement disparu du
texte à l'unstar du ministre du Travail
qui n'est toujours pas là aujourd'hui
qui a déserté les débats résultat il ne
s'agit plus que d'être méchant avec les
gentil et avec tous les autres pour nous
la
solidarité la dignité humaine l'accès au
droits fondamentaux ne sont pas
négociables ils sont consubstantiels à
l'ordre public et social à gauche nous
savons ce qu'apportent les étrangers les
travailleurs comme les étudiants à la
société française nous croyons à
l'intégration par le travail par l'accès
à notre langue par l'insertion dans
notre vie associative et sociale mais
avec ce texte l'étranger n'est vu que
comme une menace un fruddeur quelqu'un
dont on peut au mieux tolérer la
présence sur notre sol alors
qu'aujourd'hui notre pays fait face à un
triple dysfonctionnement de l'accueil de
la protection
de la reconduction nous réfutons
vigoureusement ce discours simpliste
distinguant les bons et les mauvais
étrangers ainsi que le présupposé selon
lequel l'immigration économique serait
plus légitime plus noble que
l'immigration familial ou l'asile oui
nous considérons que la régularisation
par le travail est bénéfique à
l'ensemble des travailleurs là où le
travail illégal cultive la précarité et
la concurrence éloyale les travailleurs
sans papierers étant contraint
d'accepter d'indiges condition de
travail et de rémunération la non
régularisation des travailleurs sans
papierers laisse prospérer une forme
d'esclavage moderne visiblement au
regard du texte sur lequel nous devons
aujourd'hui nous exprimer ce n'est pas
la position de la majorité sénatoriale
nous sénatrices et sénateurs socialistes
nous opposons fermement à ce que vous
avez introduit la droite et son allié
centriste dans ce projet de loi avec
l'assentiment et la bienveillance du
ministre de l'intérieur nous combattons
la précarisation des étrangers que vous
voulez instaurer par la suppression de
toute allocation non contributive avant
5 années de résidence en situation
régulière punissant ainsi y compris les
enfants par votre refus de régulariser
les étrangers sans papiers dans les
métiers en tension mesure pourtant
soutenu par l'ensemble des employeurs et
par les Français par l'exclusion des
étrangers en situation irrégulière du
dispositif d'hébergement d'urgence les
condamnant donc à la rue et par votre
refus d'octroyer au demandeurs d'asile
le droit au travail des au dépôt de leur
demande les les condamnant ainsi à ce
que vous dénoncez parfois comme de
guillemets
laassistana nous ne pouvons accepter le
dénis du droit à la santé des étrangers
que vous avez opéré par la suppression
de l'aide médicale d'État qui pourtant
bénéficie à l'ensemble de la population
avec une position gouvernementale que
nous n'arrivons plus à suivre pour un
jour pour selon les ministres le
ministre de la Santé contre à titre
personnel pour le ministre de
l'Intérieur pour finalement le soir à la
télé pour finalement la première
ministre et contre finalement au
Parlement et par l'arrêt de la prise en
charge médicale des députés du droit
d'asile nous condamnons résolument vos
atteintes au droits de la nationalité
par l'élargissement que vous avez voté
de la possibilité de déchoir une
personne de C nationalité par la
restriction du droit du sol nous
contestons également les atteintes au
droit à une vie familiale que vous avez
introduit en durcissant considérablement
l'accès au regroupement familial nous
fustigeons avec force les multiples
atteintes aux libertés au respect des
droits auquels vous avez procédé
notamment en passant à 3 années la durée
possible d'une assignation à résidence
enfin nous critiquons les restrictions à
l'accueil des étudiants étrangers et à
l'aide au développement ou à la
politique des visas que vous avez
souhaité adopter nous faisant ainsi
courir le risque d'une dégradation du
rayonnement de la France politique que
l'ambassadeur de France au Maroc
qualifiait hier encore de gachi ce
faisant votre texte mesdames et
messieurs de la majorité sénatoriale
reprend consciencieusement en s'alignant
avec les propositions du Front National
et de marine lepen sur chacun des thèmes
évoqués lors de l'examen de ce projet de
loi votre aile la plus dure à emporter
le groupe LR avec le soutien du groupe
centriste sur un texte pourtant peu
conforme à ses idéos et avec la
complaisance inquiétante du gouvernement
mais également du groupe des sénateurs
macronistes cette dérive se poursuit
comme le désirait le Front national avec
la proposition de loi constitutionnelle
de monsieur retaillot qui viendra en
séance le 12 décembre et qui préconise
rien de moins que de se soustraire au
droit de l'Union de fixer des quotas
d'étrangers par nationalité et
d'expulser tout étranger condamné une
peine de prison nous vivons aujourd'hui
mes chers collègues un moment de
clarification la droite française ce
texte au parcours chaotique s'achève
dans un naufrage pour la droite et une
rupture avec notre modèle républicain
mais aussi avec l'héritage du gaulisme
et l'ambition de cohésion que défendait
Jacques Chirac l'un d'entre vous
écrivait il y a 18 mois messieurs du
groupe LR et mesdames du groupe LR chez
les républicains notre faiblesse a été
d'abandonner le terrain au rassemblement
national recherche synthèse avec l'autre
droite que nous combattons depuis
toujours serait contre nature et
nécessairement voué à
l'échec si nous renoncions à la fermeté
de nos convictions nous ne serions plus
rien nous incarnons un idéal qui
sonnerait être intexé aux aléas de la
vie politique sinon nous ne serions plus
que de simples opportunistes mesdames et
messieurs du groupe l je viens de lire
les propos de Philippe B nous le disons
aujourd'hui
solennellement majorité sénatoriale ne
vous laissez pas dériver vers une droite
extrême qui ne se satisfera jamais de
vos propositions nous le disons au
groupe centriste ne vous laissez pas
emporter par cette dérive orthogonale à
cette conception de la société ne passez
pas du compromis à la compromission il
est encore temps de mettre un terme à
cette dérive pour notre part groupe
socialiste nous prenons nos
responsabilité en nous opposant avec
force à une vision de la France étroite
et menacée par chaque éang vision qui
n'est pas la
nôtre
bon la parole est maintenant au
président François Noël buffet pour le
compl
[Applaudissements]
républicain
chers
[Applaudissements]
collègues monsieur le Président vousvez
la parole merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre Mesdames et Messieurs les
rapporteurs ce n'est pas comme président
de la commission des lois que je
m'exprime mais au nom du groupe les
républicains
je voudrais vous dire au moment où nous
abordons le vote officiel de ce texte
qu'il faut laisser de côté soit les
injures soit les caricatures et qu'il
faut tout de même regarder ce qu'est la
réalité il n'y a il n'y a je crois comme
base de travail que celle-ci qui vaille
le reste peut-être une une idée une
vision une conception mais elle Ste
toujours sur la réalité des faits or
l'ensemble des analyses qui ont été
faites par le Sénat depuis longtemps sur
ce domaine est largement documenté et
d'ailleurs sur le fond jamais
contesté le contexte vous le connaissez
c'est une pression migratoire sans
précédent régulière de 316000 premers
titres en 2022 comme irrégulière 400000
bénéficiaires de la M est estimé par le
ministre lui-même à plus de 900000
personnes sur le territoire national et
une incapacité très grande de pouvoir
pour pour pardon pour le pouvoir public
de réagir à cette intensification de
flux la conséquence et regardonsle en
face les Français d'ailleurs le
considère ainsi un processus
d'intégration qui est grippé pour ne pas
dire qui ne fonctionne pas ce dont nous
devons nous désoler des taux
d'éloignement qui ne sont pas bons
chacun le sait tous les chiffres sont
connus les octf c'est de l'ordre de 7 %
c'est évidemment largement insuffisant
on a eu l'occasion de s'exprimer sur les
raisons et une chaîne de l'asile au bord
de l'implosion 160000 demandes projetées
en 2024 un délai moyen de 11 mois pour
traiter les demandes des dossiers alors
que nous espérions à l'origine 6 mois
quelles sont les causes de cette
situation nous pensons pour la majorité
sénatoriale et pour le groupe que je
représente ici c'est d'abord une absence
de vision en terme de politique
migratoire tant que la France n'aura pas
déterminé la politique migratoire
qu'elle souhaite il n'y aura que des
échecs et nous avons souhaiter fixer
cette politique migratoire dans le texte
clairement de manière à ce que les
choses soient parfaitement clair pour
tout le monde je dire et que les mesures
qui en découlent soient parfaitement
cohérentes alors ce texte est arrivé par
le gouvernement il y a plusieurs mois
maintenant avec à peu près 27 articles à
l'origine il va ressortir de cet
hémicycle avec plus de 90 articles
faut-il donc considérer que le Sénat a
largement travaillé largement contribué
probablement modifié une grande partie
de ce texte là pour répondre à la
proposition que nous avons faite qui est
celle d'un texte et d'une stratégie
clairement établie alors bien évidemment
l'examen en commission a eu lieu les
rapporteurs ont profondément travaillé
et nous avons déterminé six piliers
d'abord la maîtrise maîtriser les voies
d'accès au séjour et lutter contre
l'immigration irrégulière muscler la
politique d'intégration pour que les
choses soient parfaitement clair quand
on dit muscler c'est l'améliorer lui
donner de la qualité pour permettre une
intégration des étrangers sur le
territoire national ce n'est pas pour
les bloquer c'est simplement pour
décider que une fois qu'ils sont rentrés
sur le territoire national et qu'ils
bénéficient d'un titre de séjour ils
doivent être intégrés rapidement dans
les meilleures conditions possible pour
qu'il s'intègre à la vie commune c'est
pas autre chose autoriser l'éloignement
des étrangers ne respectant pas nos lois
et valeurs c'est nouveau et c'est
essentiel cela vient dans la continuité
du texte valeur de la République agir
pour la mise en effectif de décision
d'éloignement bien sûr mieux encadrer la
réforme de l'asile parce qu'il faut
impérativement que nous retrouvions de
l'efficacité et enfin et enfin parce que
personne n'en parle et pourtant c'est
essentiel c'est la le PER la perfection
le perfectionnement pardon de la réforme
du contentieux de façon à avoir trois
procédures finalement applicables qui
permettront de j'allais dire soulager le
terme est sans doute réel mais en la
matière faciliter le travail de nos
magistrats administratifs et puis le
texte est arrivé en séance publique il a
eu également là à nouveau des débats
importants sur la maîtrise des voies
d'accès au séjour de la nationalité à
laquelle notre groupe a largement
participé et largement musclé les choses
je ne rentre pas dans le détail sur la
lutte de l'immigration irrégulière on
évoquit tout à l'heure les questions de
l'ame et notre collègue disait vous vous
n'alz pas soigner les gens et en plus
vous allez supprimer les allocations
familiales petite précision mon cher
cèue collègue les allocations les
prestations familiales non contribut
il faut quand même cette précision me
paraît importante sur la politique
d'intégration alors le fameux article 3
nous sommes contre l'intégration par le
travail c'est ce que vous dites à tu
tête de partout on n jamais dit ça on a
simplement dit que le travail
l'intégration par le travail et pour
obtenir un titre de séjour pour
travailler dans les M les métiers en
tension devait répondre à un certain
nombre de règles que nous n'avons pas
voulu ce que prévoyait l'article 3
avoir régularisation mass et automatique
parce qu'elle constituait un appel d'air
considérable et oui nous devons le
confirmer et que nous avons changé le
dispositif avec un moyen confié une
procédure confiée au préfet dans le
cadre de l'admission exceptionnelle au
séjour et je crois que nous avons bien
fait et pour ceux qui nous regardent ce
qu'il faut qu'il sachent c'est que les
étrangers ayant un contrat de travail
dans des métiers en tension pourront
être régularisés sur le territoire
national par le préfet à la condition
qu'ils en fassent naturellement leur
demande au titre de l'admission
exceptionnelle au séjour et que la
réalité du travail soit contrôlée voilà
la réalité de ce que nous avons
enfin bien sûr
que nous avons travaillé encore sur la
mise en œuvre des décisions
d'éloignement nous savons que le sujet
est difficile et compliqué mais que la
mesure doit être ferme et si je devais
parce que dans quelques instants je
devrais rendre la parole traduire ce
qu'a voulu la majorité sénatoriale nos
rapporteur mais le groupe auquel
j'appartiens en particulier c'est que
d'abord l'immigration régulière soit
choisie et que l'État décide de son
choix et qu'il l'affirme clairement et
que le nôtre c'est celui d'une
immigration économique qualitative nous
ne l'avons pas inventé tout seul
naturellement peut-être qu'on serait
peut-être pas capable je n'en sais rien
mais en tous les cas nous avons nous
sommes basés sur le rapport de l'OCDE je
l'ai déjà dit à cette tribune il y a
déjà plusieurs semaines c'est une
intégration de qualité la volonté de
renforcer les moyens d'apprentissage du
français du niveau de français la
volonté de devoir respecter les valeurs
de la République c'est une une
intégration donc de qualité nous devons
nous évidemment ce de les moyens pour
cela il n'est pas question qu'il en soit
autrement ça ne peut pas être une
intégration au rabeis ou simplement pour
dire que on peut ENF simplement on Rabet
et puis enfin sur l'immigration
irrégulière et bien oui c'est tolérance
zéro et bien oui c'est tolérance zéro
c'est d'abord parce que quand on est en
situation régulière sur le territoire
national que par ailleurs on est arrivé
via des réseaux et d'autres moyens et
qu'on essaie de s'y maintenir à tout
prix et bien c'est non que les choses
soit clair et puis c'est aussi une
mesure de justice en réalité à l'égard
de ceux qui font les démarches
régulières qui veulent vien
régulièrement sur le territoire et qui
s'intègre complètement et bien c'est
aussi pour eux que cela est nécessaire
pour qu'ils puissent inégrer
parfaitement dans notre société enfin et
j'en terminerai par là enfin j'en
terminerai par là l'asile il faut
protéger la procédure d'asile bien
évidemment qu'il faut appliquer la
convention de Genève bien évidemment
qu'il faut accorder le statut de réfugié
à tous ceux qui en ont besoin et pour
qui c'est nécessaire mais bien
évidemment qu'il faut lutter contre les
réseaux de voyou qui profitent de faut
concl
Président on mimpose de terminer je
termine monsieur le Président je ne vous
impose rien je régule monsieur le
Président donne la
parole pour la Réunion administrative
des sédateurs ne figurant sur la liste
d'aucun groupe monsieur Christopher
Zurek monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Ministre madame
monsieur le rapporteur mes chers
collègues pouvez calmer madame merci un
acte manqué je ne serais mieux résumé
que par mot ce dont accouche finalement
le Sénat tout n'avait pas si mal
commencé nous avions eu quelques espoirs
lorsque notre assemblée accepta un soir
de transformer l'aide médicale d'État en
une plus juste aide médicale d'urgence
mesure que nous appelons de nos vux
depuis de longues années au
rassemblement national et qui permet
d'aller vers une solidarité plus
recentré vers nos compatriotes sans
évidemment abandonner quiconque se
retrouvera en urgence vitale à ce titre
et permettez-moi cette parenthèse il me
faut inévitablement m'insurger contre le
le dépôt de plainte visant deux de nos
collègues médecins au motif de leur vote
dépôt de plainte évidemment symbolique
et pénalement foutraque mais qui atteste
d'une volonté de pression sur les
législateurs alors non tout n'est pas
mauvais mais à la faveur des
tergiversations de la majorité
sénatoriale le péché original de ce
texte revenait certes par la petite
porte mais revenez tout de même puisque
nous restons persuadé que l'article 4
bis ne sera en rien un frein à
l'immigration illégale et au travail
clandestin certes ce n'est plus
exactement un droit opposable mais nous
savons tous très bien ce que cela
donnera dans la pratique et
fondamentalement vous-même vous le savez
alors quel gâachi cet article dont nous
avons déjà pu débattre mercredi soir et
qui ront à nos yeux ce texte sans esprit
de rupture avec les politiques
d'incitation à l'immigration que nous
dénonçons nous savons par ailleurs que
le gouvernement va tenter de caviarder
ce texte le président macroniste de la
commission des lois à l'Assemblée
nationale l'a déjà annoncé et géralde
daranin a aussi manifesté sa volonté de
cornaquer le travail des députés
finalement c'est sans doute le signe que
le référendum que nous proposons est la
seule issue démocratiquement viable sur
ce sujet les Français nous le savons
sont en accord avec avec les
dispositions que nous défendons au
premier rang desqueles la fin du rur du
sol et la priorité nationale dès lors il
me faut profiter de l'occasion qui m'est
donné pour réaffirmer notre vision de la
communauté nationale Bainville disait
dans sa fondatrice histoire de France
que je cite le peuple français est un
composé c'est mieux qu'une race c'est
une nation quelques décennies plus tôt
Renant expliquer la nation comme une
adhésion collective qui ne trouve
évidemment pas ses sources dans l'ethnie
ni dans les origines mais bel et bien
dans le regroupement autour d'une
volonté et de valeurs communes et c'est
cela notre vision de la France une
volonté commune d'aller vers une même
destinée et dès lors l'immigration ne
peut se faire que dans un consentement
mutuel des arrivants mais surtout des
accueillants les Français ne sont pas
racistes ni xénophobes ni
fondamentalement opposés à une
immigration raisonnable ils considèrent
simplement comme nous que nous n'avons
plus les moyens de l'assumer il ne
s'agit évidemment pas de haine des
autres mais surtout d'une envie de
protéger les nôtres l'actualité est tant
cruelle je ne mentionnerai pas les six
mineurs migrants isolés interpellés ce
matin après des coups de fil dans le
quartier des Moulins à Nice ce texte
aurait pu aurait dû être une
démonstration de courage nous déplorons
comme le disait ce matin le député al
Pradier qu'il soit une reculade nous
voterons donc contre ce texte je vous
remercie la parole est à notre collègue
Pierrejean verzelen pour le groupe des
indépendants République et
territoire avez la
parole monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre
monsieur le Président de la Commission
mesdames Messieurs les rapporteurs mes
chers
collègues la lutte contre l'immigration
illégale et l'intégration sont devenus
depuis de longues années et pour
beaucoup de Français synonyme d'échec
d'impuissance publique et le symbole
d'une forme de faillite de l'état d'un
côté un état surnormé suradministré qui
a le goût du contrôle permanent dans
beaucoup de domaines et de l'autre
un état qui paraît depuis longtemps
démuni et dépassé quand on parle
d'immigration le sentiment que ce sujet
lui échappe et qu'en la matière nous ne
sommes plus souverains plus maître de
notre destin c'est cet écart ce paradoxe
j'allais dire qui nourrit les
incompréhensions et parfois les les
colères chez les
Français le gouvernement a choisi de
déposer un texte régalien en première
lecture au Sénat ce projet s'appuie sur
travail et le rapport de notre collègue
François Noël buffet ce texte il était
attendu il était
nécessaire les débats ont été animés
parfois ouleux mais toujours correct et
après l'étude de près de 700 amendements
nous arrivons au terme de ce texte
chacune et chacun pourra objectivement
monsieur le ministre saluer votre
intérêt pour le travail parlementaire et
votre implication lors des débats
au-delà des points de vues des conv
viiction et parfois disons le des
postures nous l'avons vérifié pendant
tous les débats la régulation de
l'immigration et
l'intégration sont dans la pratique
devenus tellement techniques tellement
juridiques ils empilent ils additionnent
ils accumule depuis 40 ans une multitude
de lois de circulaires de décret et à la
fin cette complexité elle nuit à la
clarté et certainement à la capacité
d'agir alors ce texte il va permettre
des avancées
significatives déjà un renforcement à
l'égard de ceux qui vivent de la misère
et de la détresse des plus faibles de
ceux qui n'ont pas de respect pour la
dignité humaine nous parlons ici des
passeurs des marchands de sommeil et des
patrons voyou un consensus s'est dégagé
sur la nécessité de tenir un débat
annuel sur la politique migratoire c'est
une bonne nouvelle on parlait
d'immigration partout dans le pays et
tout le temps il est logique que nous en
parlions au moins une fois par an au
Parlement ce sera l'occasion de
déterminer les quotas pour décider des
besoins de notre
société les Français et on le comprend
attendent plus de fermeté un certain
nombre de dispositions vont permettre
l'expulsion des étrangers qui menacent
gravement l'ordre public ou encore ceux
qui sont condamnés à des actes de
violence les délinquants étrangers n'ont
pas leur place sur le territoire
national nous souscrivons pleinement au
lev des protections contre l'expulsion
les auteurs d'infraction lourdes ne
pourront plus se maintenir sur notre sol
la faculté pour un juge de prononcer une
interdiction du territoire français en
cas de condamnation pour un crime ou un
délit de plus de 3 ans sera donc enfin
généralisé avec tous les recours
possibles devant les tribunaux devant le
Conseil d'État c'est souvent au bout
d'un délai de 3 ans que l'on peut dire
définitivement à un étranger si oui ou
non il peut rester en France cette loi
va permettre de raccourcir
significativement ces délais ce sera
donc le moyen le plus efficace
de faire appliquer ces fameuses otf les
obligations de quitter le territoire
français c'est le moment de réaffirmer
clairement qu'il n'existe pas en France
de droit opposable au séjour le contrôle
du territoire et celui de la population
sont des éléments constitutif de la
souveraineté des États la France ne peut
pas la France ne doit pas s'en
départir notre groupe est satisfait du
compromis trouvé sur la régularisation
prévue pour les métiers en
tension les préfets que les intéressés
sont véritablement
intégrés que leur démarche ne
dépendent sans que les démarches pardon
ne dépendent que du bon vouloir de
l'employeur et finalement comme
l'ensemble des parties prenantes de cet
accord estime toutes et tous avoir eu
gain de cause c'est certainement le
signe que l'article 4 bis est donc un
bon
compromis la régularisation tout comme
l'accueil légal d'étranger ne peut pas
se faire au détriment de la cohésion
nationale notre priorité doit être une
intégration réussie nous l'avons
tellement loupé depuis longtemps
tellement négligé avec les conséquences
que nous connaissons aujourd'hui
l'étranger qui arrive en France devra se
rengager à respecter les valeurs de
notre République la liberté de
conscience la liberté d'expression
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
le non respect de ces engagements
donnera lieu un retrait du titre de
séjour il faudra là aussi veiller à
l'application de ces
sanctions
les étrangers admis à résider
durablement dans notre P dans notre pays
pardon doivent maîtriser notre langue
l'obligation de réussite à l'examen de
français n'est pas un obstacle mais bien
au contraire une condition de la
réussite de l'intégration Camu écrivait
ma Patrice c'est la langue française le
partage de la langue c'est ce qui permet
d'interagir avec l'autre de transmettre
de comprendre l'histoire de se respecter
parfois de s'aimer de s'intégrer de
s'assimiler la langue c'est la pierre
angulaire de toute intégration
réussie
ce ce projet de loi naturellement
s'inscrit dans un cadre européen et
reste soumis aux évolutions
géopolitiques mondiales au sein de
l'espace Schengen la liberté de
circulation des personnes rend d'autant
plus cruciale la maîtrise de nos
frontières extérieures soulignons ici le
travail de l'agence Frontex qui en a la
responsabilité son financement a été
accru et il faut veiller à renforcer
encore ces moyens
les défis auxquels notre pays est
confronté sont immenses les crises
d'aujourd'hui nourrissent les migration
de demain les guerres les famines le
réchauffement climatique la démographie
conduiront à des flux migratoires plus
important vers notre continent les
relations diplomatiques et économiques
avec les pays d'migration sont un enjeu
majeur essentiel pour la reconduite des
immigrés illégaux dans leur pays
d'origine
pour en terminer ce projet de loi
modifié par le Sénat partira bientôt à
l'Assemblée nationale alors on entend on
lit certaines et certains indiquer que
cette version du texte sera détricotée
que les compteurs seront remis à zéro je
cite dans le texte nous vous demandons
Monsieur le Ministre de veiller à ce que
le résultat d'un débat et d'un travail
parlementaire approfondi soit respecté à
l'Assemblée
nationale
[Applaudissements]
l'ensemble des élus du groupe Les
Indépendants voteront en faveur de
l'adoption du projet de loi je vous
remercie de votre
attention la parole est à notre
collègue Isabelle Floren pour le groupe
de l'Union
[Applaudissements]
centriste z la parole merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Ministre Madame et
Monsieur le les rapporteurs mes chers
collègues au début de l'examen de ce
texte nous avions une crainte assez rare
dans cet hémicycle que nous ne
parvenions pas à un accord sur
l'ensemble du texte en en mars dernier
la discussion avait été riche lors de
l'examen en commission et elle a été
également en séance la semaine passée
aujourd'hui nous sommes satisfaits que
nous puiss adopté un texte sur une
problématique aussi importante pour nos
concitoyens notre assemblée aura fait
œuvre utile et c'est tant mieux le texte
que nous nous apprêtons à voter a bien
changé depuis son dépôt sur le bureau du
Sénat le 1er février il s'est d'abord
étaufé le nombre d'articles additionnels
que nous avons adopté est assez
inhabituel cela montre d'abord une chose
la version initiale du projet de loi
présentait plusieurs manques que notre
assemblée a bien vu combler le texte ne
prévoyait rien en matière notamment de
regroupement familial de contrôle de
l'immigration étudiante alors que des
évolutions étaient indispensables nous
aurions aussi voulu aller plus loin sur
un sujet brûlant des mineurs non
accompagnés mais certains de nos
amendements ont malheureusement été
frappés de l'article 40 il était aussi
nécessaire de renforcer le rôle du
Parlement nous avons souhaité qu'il
puisse fixer dans le cadre d'un débat
annuel et pour chacune des catégories de
séjour à l'exception de l'asile le
nombre d'étrangers admis en France enfin
les débats en séance ont permis d'aller
plus loin sur certains aspects du texte
notamment à la lumière de l'actualité
dramatique de l'attentat d'aras le Sénat
a ainsi facilité la levée des
protections contre les expulsions et les
interdiction du territoire français en
en supprimant certaines et en
généralisant la possibilité de les
prononcer nous avons également rétabli
en séance l'obligation pour un employeur
de prendre en charge les frais de
formation à l'apprentissage du français
certains aménagements ont suscité des
doutes ou des des réticences au sein de
notre groupe c'est notamment le cas des
dispositions de l'article 1er n adopté
en séance prévoyant de conditionner
l'ouverture des droits aux prestations
sociales non contributives à 5 années de
résidence stable et R rgulire je
rappelle qu'il s'agit des allocations
familiales de la prestation de
compensation handicap ou encore de
l'aide personnalisée au logement pour
plusieurs membres de notre groupe ce
délai de 5 années est trop long si
aujourd'hui ce dégalage existe déjà je
rappelle qu'il n'était que de 6 mois et
que nous l'avons étendu à 5 ans de la
même manière la modification de l'aide
médicale d'État a suscité certaines
réaction pour autant ce débat va se
prolonger à l'Assemblée nationale et en
commission mixte paritaire mais si nous
pouvons être honnête il y a une part de
mauvaise foi des deux côtés ceux d'abord
qui nous annonce de manière tonitruante
que nous avons supprimé et que c'est
très bien que nous l'avons supprimé et
que c'est très Blin ne rappelle pas
toujours que nous avons surtout changé
son nom en aide médicale d'urgence et
réduit ainsi son panier de soins de même
ceux qui s'indignent de l'inhumanité de
cette suppression faut aussi semblant de
ne pas voir que cette aimu qui en
réalité ne laissera personne mourir
d'une pathologie grave sur notre sol
qu'il soit français ou étranger en
situation
irrégulière un compromis je rappelle
n'est pas une comprimission
compromission mes chers collègues ils
font donc revenir des deux de côtés des
deux côtés à plus de sérénité et arrêter
les déclarations trop radicales qui ne
reflètent pas ce que le Sénat a
réellement
voté enfin nous saluons l'accord qui est
intervenu au sein de la majorité
sénatoriale sur la question des métiers
en tension personne ne voulait ni au
groupe LR ni au groupe UC de la création
d'un titre de séjour créant un droit
opposable à la régularisation nous en
sommes sortis par le haut et je tiens à
saluer particulièrement les rapporteurs
ainsi que la le président de la
commission des lois qui ont permis que
nous parvenions à cet accord ce
compromis pragmatique démontre une
nouvelle fois l'utilité du travail du
Sénat mais une question est maintenant
dans toutes les têtes monsieur le
ministre que va-t-il se passer
maintenant monsieur le ministre j'espère
que vous avez profité de cette semaine
au Palais du Luxembourg
car ce n'était finalement qu'un
échauffement minutieux j'ai bien peur
qu'au palais Burbon ce ne soit bien plus
acrimonieux le Sénat sera naturellement
à l'écoute de ce que feront les députés
mais sur plusieurs aspects du texte vous
avez bien compris que nous pourrons
difficilement transiger nous conservons
l'espoir que le texte qui sera adopté à
l'Assemblée nationale permettra ensuite
d'avoir un dialogue constructif en
commission paritaire mais nous ne
pourrons pas vous suivre si les apports
du S sont systématiquement remis en
cause par la majorité à l'Assemblée
l'examen en commission des lois qui
débutera fin novembre nous donnera des
signaux auxquels nous serons attentif
pour l'heure le groupe Union centriste
votera très majoritairement en faveur du
texte issu des délibérations de notre
haute assemblée je vous
remercie
appeler notre collègue GUID bénaroche
pour le groupe écologie solidarité et
[Applaudissements]
territoire avez la parole merci monsieur
le Président Monsieur le Président
Mesdames Messieurs monsieur le ministre
madames msieurs les rapporteurs chers
collègues nous y sommes donc face à un
texte dont le parcours chaotique et les
débats ératiques feront hélas date
travailler partiellement février sorti
de l'ordre du jour au prêtemp revenu en
cette fait d'automne telle que la
Commission l'avait voté malgré les
déclarations du président de la
République nos discussions n'ont pas été
à la hauteur du sujet la réalité des
flux migratoires croissant et les
solutions indispensable pour intégrer
les étrangers qui continueront à arriver
malgré les barrières qu'on peut mettre
administrativ ou physique devrait être à
la base de toutes les réflexions de
toutes les décisions de toutes les
décisions législatives mais pas votre
déniis débouchant sur un panel de
mesures toutes plus pénalisante
répressive dans le seul objet de vouloir
freiner la régularisation l'arrivée
l'intégration des migrants dans notre
pays quelle vision séparatiste de notre
société ce texte a été capté par la
guerre fratricide que le gouvernement et
la majorité sénatoriale se sont livré
d'un côté certains dans cet hémicycle
ont choisi ce sujet pour se démarquer de
la majorité présidentielle et ce sont
déplacé très majoritairement sur leur
droite sans complexe de l'utre le
gouvernement ne voulant pas paraître
moins 10 ans sur la fermeté affiché a
donné bien des avis favorables comme
pour le rétablissement du délit de
séjour irrégulier ou sur les
restrictions de regroupement familial y
compris au conjoint de français en
acceptant ainsi tant d'aggravation dans
texte initial déjà exagérément
sécuritaire les deux cas aujourd'hui
revendiquent une victoire politique sur
le dos non seulement des migrants mais
aussi des valeurs rassembleuses de notre
démocratie même les centristes du Sénat
revendiquent une victoire sur l'article
3 renommé 4 additionnel et pourtant vidé
de toute sa substance l'instauration
d'un droit à la régularisation de
certains travailleurs sans papier n'aura
pas lieu si le texte présenté
aujourd'hui est voté oubliez aussi la
possibilité de travail immédiat pour les
demandeurs d'asile avec le rejet de
l'article 4 quel que soit le devenir ou
la vocation à rester sur notre
territoire l'accès au travail c'est une
automisation et une intégration qui
débute chers collègues vous ne pouveit
pas accepter ces abandants cyniques ce
texte initialement très déséquilibré est
devenu un infamme repoussoir dans toute
la gestion de ce projet de loi actuel et
futur la cohérence d'une vision
réfléchie et constructive de
l'intégration et de l'arrivée des
étrangers en France a été sacrifié à des
jeux de rapports de force politique
la politisation outrossière de la
question migratoire est un piège qui ne
profite à personne ou alors à quelle fr
de notre sphère politique les quelques
amendements identiques de la droite et
de l'extrême droite voté ici nous le
démontrent la société ne sort pas adè
d'une libération de la vision de
l'étranger comme un danger la xénophobie
est une haine de l'autre contre tous les
racismes contre toutes les
discriminations notre lutte doit être
sans con
sans calcul sans arrière-pensée tel ne
fut pas le cas peut-être un futur
référendum présidentiel écartera comme
la majorité de cette hémicycle a fait
d'ailleurs les pauvres anglais
propriétaires dés désormais exemptés de
visa car c'est difficile de solliciter
un permis de séjour ou un visa procédure
longue et complexifié par de nombreuxes
alléas techniques mais pourquoi pour eux
seulement c'est insupportable de ne pas
individualiser les parcours
d'immigration et de faire des catégories
de banes étranges des catégories de B
travailleurs nous avons assisté à une
accumulation de dispositions enfin
disons plutôt de marqueur électoraliste
revendiquer comm tel tous basés sur
l'idée que l'étranger est un danger ou
une charge souvent avec l'invocation l'
encore entendu aujourd'hui d'un appel
d'air pourtant jamais observé jamais
corroboré jamais démontré par aucune
étude ou aucun chiffre vous avez préféré
le récit et la sable et la croyance
plutôt que l'analyse réaliste les
chiffres l'humanité la vie des gens la
réalité que vous avez tout à fait oublié
monsieur le Président buffet vous y
référiez notre pays ne peut pas mettre
les gens dans des situations irrégulière
vis-à-vis de la loi du flet de la
complexité croissante de l'inflation
législative notre pays ne doit pas
participer à la précarisation des
étrangers mais qu'a décidé la majorité
de cette hémicycle souvent avec le
soutien du gouvernement vous avez voté
la suppression de
l'Ame déclarant est très attaché à l'AME
le gouvernement qui l'a défendu en
développant des arguments indiscutables
a abandonné sa défense en race campagne
face à ce toc des
républicains cette suppression est une
faute de l'avis même du ministre de la
Santé les Français soutiennent la me les
professionnels soutiennent la me les
études et les retours d'expérience
démontre l'utilité d'une telle mesure le
rapporteur malgré cela a insisté à jouer
sur des arguments d'une bassesse rare
jouant la précarité de certains de nos
concitoyens et leur difficulté d'accès
aux soins pour justifier une telle
suppression nous écologistes pensons que
nos concitoyens sont dés de fraternité
et qu'ils savent que dégrader les
conditions de vie de quelques personnes
fragiles ne participera pas à améliorer
leur situation si vous voulez que les
Français puissent mieux se soigner il y
a tant d'autres mesures à prendre cette
suppression celle des articles 3 et 4
ont bien enterré un équ bre promis très
très précaire du texte initial et vite
jeté aux oubliettes par le gouvernement
le texte s construit dans une vision
toujours plus restrictive reposant sur
plus d'automaticité pour les sanctions
mais aucune pour les régularisations non
de bon travailleur intégré devra rester
à la mercie de son employeur soumis à
l'arbitraire de l'analyse d'un préfet
plus d'automacité pour la suppression de
l'accompagnement le retrait des aPL les
expulsurs de logement les sorties sèches
de l'aide sociale à l'enfance mais
aucune pour les régularisations le droit
au travail des demandeurs d'asile ou
même conserver la collégialité de
l'étude des recours à la CNDA avec le
représentant du haut commomissariat des
nations- Unies et que dire de toutes les
mesures que nous va que vous n'avez pas
souhaité discuter les réfugiés
climatiques par exemple pas le sujet
bien sûr alors que l'Australie vient de
commencer à accorder l'asile pour les
habitants de tuvalue mais cette loi
immigration n'est pas le vent vaisseau
vous nous avez-vous dit par contre vous
êtes tous jetés sur la bête pour y
ajouter les sujets de la nationalité
compliquant au restreignant son accès y
compris pour ceux qui sont nés ici ce
texte révèle une vision décomplexée
rabougri retrécie de rejet
d'ostracisation de certains étrangers et
des migrants oublier leur participation
à notre société à notre développement à
notre histoire le Bou ébissè est revenu
pour CV et ce texte participe c'est le
signe d'une dérive nous ne vont pas
l'accompagner par des lois dans ces
conditions nous rejetons ce texte
indigne notre groupe votera contre avec
force et
[Applaudissements]
conviction monsieur le
ministre chers collègues il va être
procédé dans les conditions prévues par
l'article 56 de notre règlement au
scrutin public solennel sur l'ensemble
du projet de loi pour contrôler
l'immigration et améliorer
l'intégration le scrutin sera ouvert
dans quelques
instants je vous invite à insérer votre
carte de vote dans le terminal et à le
laisser jusqu'à la fin du
vote si vous disposez d'une délégation
de vote le nom du sénateur pour lequel
vous devez voter s'affiche
automatiquement sur le terminal en
dessous de votre nom vous pouvez alors
voter pour vous et pour le délégant en
sélectionnant le nom correspondant puis
en choisissant une position de vote
oui je peux ouvrir le scrutin est
ouvert
quelqu'un demande encore à
voter deme encore à
voter ne demande à voter le scrutin est
donc
clos
voici les
résultats du scrutin qui porte le numéro
43 sur l'ensemble du texte contenu de
l'ensemble des délégations de vote
nombre de votants
341 nombre de suffrages exprimés 325
pour l'adoption 210 contre 115 le Sénat
a donc
[Applaudissements]
adopté je vais maintenant donner la
parole au ministre de l'Intérieur les
autres ma monsieur
Gérald merci merci monsieur le Président
permettez-moi tout d'abord monsieur le
président
de remercier tous tous les
collaborateurs qui s'agissent du
gouvernement au CE de votre assemblée
pour cette semaine de travail je pense
que nous l'avons fait de manière
politique à l'écoute répondant aux
arguments de chacune et chacun j'ai
espéré être à la auteur de ce
qu'attendait la Haute Assemblée du
ministre de l'Intérieur je remercie
monsieur le président de la commission
des lois les deux rapporteurs avecqu
nous avons les désaccords mais un
travail très important je remercie donc
François Noë buffet Philippe boncère et
Madame Jourda etcier remercier tous les
sénateurs parce que je tend bien que
désormais la presse et la télévision
regardit les orateurs à discussion
générale mais ça m'a pas paru vraiment
ce que nous avons vécu depuis une
semaine je rappelle que le gouvernement
a donné des avis favorables et a adopté
d'ailleurs cette assemblée dans sa
diversité adopté des amendements venant
de tous les bancs y compris comme vous
l'avez très bien dit avec hnêé Monsieur
brossa que je remercie je voudrais dire
au groupes de la gauche que c'est pas
parce que vous êtes contre ce texte
qu'il fallait le caricaturer au moins
monsieur brossa a eu l'honnêteté de dire
que les dispositions ont été reprises et
amélioreront le sort d'une partie de ce
texte monsieur le
Président je voudrais dire également que
il y a 1 an il y a 6 mois il y a 3 mois
il y a 15 jours je pense que pas grand
monde peut-être dans votre assemblée
d'ailleurs mais surtout l'extérieur
n'aurit parié pour que le texte du
Gouvernement présenté en commission des
lois certes modifié certes modifié dans
des façons comme l'a très bien dit le
groupe des pays qui ne convient pas
absolument au gouvernement soit adopté y
compris avec une mesure de
régularisation je m'en félicite c'était
l'objectif qu'avait fixé le gouvernement
dans un dans une assemblée qui compte
moins de 40 sénateurs qui le soutient à
priori et je voudrais dire qu'il va avec
l'envie de discuter l'envie de compromis
à l'Assemblée nationale où il y a
également vous le savez une majorité
relative et je l'espère de tout mon cœur
une CMP conclusive pour le bien non pas
du gouvernement de la Haute Assemblée ou
de l'Assemblée nationale mais pour le
bien des Français fermeté contre les
étrangers délinquants meilleures
conditions d'intégration augmentation de
ces moys d'intégration simplification
des procédures voilà quel projet de loi
du gouvernement je terminerai par dire
monsieur le Président et je veux dire à
chacune et à chacun à ceux qui à gauche
disaient vous verrez quand on sera en
responsabilité nous le ferons je
rappelle et c'est bien dommage je pas
l'avoir rappelé que le Président de la
République est le premier des présidents
à proposé qu'il n'y ait pas de mineur
dans les centres de rétention
administratif pas un mot à la tribune
quand la gauche en 60 ans n'a pas été
capable de cette moindre mesurees
progressiste je rappelle que pour la
première fois vous avez un gouvernement
qui oblige les employeurs à apprendre le
français pendant le temps de travail pas
une seule fois en 50 ans gouvernement
socialiste ne l'a proposé je
rappelle que ce gouvernement vous
propose et je pense que c'est
extrêmement important les cours gratuits
sur un amendement monsieur brossa du
groupe communiste pas une seule fois le
groupe socialiste l'a proposé quand en
responsabilité cela me fait penser
madame de la Gonterie a une très jolie
phrase de clémenenceau il disait
toujours lorsqu'il était à l'Assemblée
nationale on on repère les les discours
de Monsieur Jess à ceci que les verbes
sont toujours
futur merci Monsieur le Ministre moi je
voudrais aussi remercier la commission
des lois ses rapporteurs
et naturellement les collaborateurs qui
ont été à la tâche de de la commission
les administrateurs et ensemble des
collègues la séance est donc suspendue
elle reprendra à
16h pour l'examen du projet de loit de
financement de la sécurité sociale pour